crétaire d'état américain qui est donc
en visite en moldavie deux sortes tout
d'abord deux sortes d' aide humanitaire
il ya l'aide humanitaire à proprement
parler puis à l'aide militaires avec des
armes de défense là il a insisté sur le
montant de l'aide humanitaire que les
états unis vont apporter alors en
réalité le le discours de blink n
insiste bien sur trois choses d'abord
tout à fait de manière tout à fait
précise est évidente l'importance que la
moldavie mais dans l'ensemble tous les
pays du flanc est de l'europe ont pour
les états unis et la manière dont les
washington entend se rapprocher de tous
ses partenaires pour justement les
renforcer et les rassurer et cela passe
effectivement par deux choses la demande
spéciale qui serait faite au congrès et
qui est massive elle ne concerne pas
simplement la moldavie elle concerne en
réalité cette aide impressionnante
d'abord vers les ukrainiens qui fuit et
vers la situation humanitaire
catastrophique
que l'on observe et qui traduit en fait
la dégradation de la situation sur le
terrain et puis on observe aussi que
ce ce lien à la fois et cette annonce de
renforcement se fait dans d'autres
domaines il a mentionné et ça me paraît
intéressant la nécessité de découpler
les réseaux énergétiques et dax
d'achever une souveraineté énergétique
par exemple pour la moldavie ce qui
montre bien et ça a été rappelé tout au
long de
de ces derniers jours à quel point pour
les pays européens la dépendance au gaz
russe et le chantage énergétique que
fait la russie et est un est un souci il
a rappelé aussi l'intégrité territoriale
avertissements puisqu'on sait qu'à la
région de la transnistrie en moldavie
qui est soutenu par les russes aient
parlé de la création d'un statut spécial
alors sur la création d'un statut
spécial il faudra voir ce dont il s'agit
en revanche c'est vrai que la
transnistrie c'est un conflit gelé c'est
un conflit gelé depuis des années 1990
et ce n'est pas simplement une enclave
c'est véritablement un endroit où vous
avez la présence d'une armée russe alors
elle est pas très nombreuses elle est
peut-être même d'ailleurs pas très bien
formés mais elle est quand même présente
c'est à dire qu'on a en moldavie 1 une
zone entière où vous avez quasiment aux
frontières de l'europe bien évidemment à
nouveau mais l'ukraine nounou lheureux
tél tous les jours bien la présence
d'unités russe est effectivement cet ex
clave russe dents
dans un pays comme la moldavie fait
peser effectivement un danger et cela
cela nous est rappelé de manière
quotidienne enfin c'est quand même sa
troisième étape d'un voyage en europe on
rappelle qu'il était en pologne anthony
blinken est ce que savent cette visite
c'est quand même pas sur le plan
maintenant diplomatique et stratégique
est ce que c'est pas un symbole du fait
que l'ukraine est un enjeu de pouvoir
entre la russie et l'otan qui est dominé
par les américains est est ce que c'est
parce que vise également le président
russe vladimir poutine je crois que
s'adresser aux américains qui domine
l'otan alors au sein de l'otan les
américains songent à dire peut-être
toujours considéré comme étant le big
dog en double mais le grand gros chien
dans l'arrière cour parce que ceux qui
appartiennent à porte dans les
opérations le maximum d'outils et de
poids par leur matériel par leur arsenal
etc mais au niveau diplomatique les
états unis ne sont pas les ceux qui
tiennent l'otan il faut bien faire
attention à cela en l'otan c'est
vraiment les 32 hier collective et les
etats unis sont l'un parmi eux parmi les
autres en revanche il est très vrai que
lorsque les pays de l'est de l'europe se
rapproche de la diplomatie américaine il
pense faire d'une pierre deux coups ils
veulent rejoindre l'otan parce que il y
a la garantie de sécurité
transatlantique et dongle parapluie
américain bien évidemment le parapluie
américain et est là et c'est toute la
crédibilité en fait de l'otan mais le
jeu de la russie c'est effectivement
discuté avec les états unis aussi c'est
à dire éviter une position de partenaire
mineur dans le jeu et bien rétablir une
égalité une parité stratégique
merci beaucoup guillaume la seconde
mariage pour votre analyse